we're just getting through to the sky
News Center a joint statement from
Liverpool Football Club Merseyside
Police norsu Liverpool City Council on
what's been described as a significant
disorder that happened last night in the
city Liverpool the second night in the
row the thousands of football fans have
been out and about celebrating
Liverpool's a Premier League title
victory very clearly concerned opposite
obviously about the lack of social
distancing that we saw and skirmishes
sir as well with the police the
statement reads through out last week
Liverpool Football Club Merseyside
Police Liverpool City Council and
spiritus Shankly have worked together to
consistently remind people that the
region is still disproportionately
affected by the Cova 19 pandemic and
asked people to celebrate Liverpool
Football Club's Premier League title win
safely however several thousand people
turned up at the pier head last night
some chose to ignore the social
distancing guidance and risk public
safety our city is still a public health
crisis this behavior is wholly
unacceptable the statement goes on to
say the potential danger of a second
peak of cope at 19 still exists we need
to work together to make sure we don't
undo everything that's been achieved as
a region during this lockdown it then
goes on to say when it is safe to do so
we will all work together to arrange a
victory parade when everyone can come
together to celebrate until that time
the safety of our city and our people
continues to be our number-one
priorities their real plea there for
football fans understandably incredibly
excited with their club's win to stay
indoors and celebrate and to adhere to
social distancing guidelines